[Music]
grammy-nominated singer david gray made
his mark of music scene two decades ago
with white ladder a self-released album
that slowly climbed to the top of the
charts he's marking that milestone with
a white ladder 20th anniversary tour a
special deluxe re-release of the album
comes out early next year
well here is greatest hit from that
album along with new music in just a
minute but first Anthony Mason who else
spoke with David Gray right here in New
York David Gray was a struggling
singer-songwriter in the late 90s with
three albums under his belt but no
breakthrough nothing really happened
commercially well one important thing
happened and that was that the music
registered in Ireland which would proved
to be very significant
he recorded his fourth album white
ladder in his London apartment and
released it on his own label in Ireland
we printed 4,000 copies when she to sell
them pressed up another five and then it
grew and grew and then the record went
gold that I lead then it went platinum
they were double platinum it's now the
biggest selling album in the history of
Ireland yeah it's it's not really as
that's behind the hit single Babylon
white ladder slowly began to catch on
around the world what was it like
watching that sort of strange slow
ascent it was great fun the vodka room
crammed three years I call it was it was
it was amazing this is an amazing
feeling there was a point that where you
kind of got sick of some of your own
biggest songs of course contending with
success and fame and and this pressure
and just being this your Babylon mr.
Babylon or just so you react against it
have you made peace with it yeah for
sure
in fact I loved playing that song
fair
for gray now 51 songs sometimes seem to
fall out of the sky this is where your
spirituality enters music in a very big
way it goes down to the the very root of
who I am and how I was born and which
was a difficult thing I was very sick
when I was a child what was it you had
as a kid I was pyloric stenosis it's
when the the muscle at the top of your
stomach seizes and you can't eat so I
was wrongly diagnosed so I was basically
starving by the time they worked out
what was wrong he nearly died the
operation when he was just a few weeks
old saved him only recently David Gray
says he's realized the importance of
that moment to his music
[Music]
when you're singing you're tapping into
something on a fundamental level
you're letting something out it's a very
healing feeling - very exhilarating
feeling it's incredibly pure yeah you're
walking on air it's you feel it's the
gift of life really you've just seen a
tiny fragment of it the created thing
your own little sort of supernova that's
created a bit of precious metals
[Music]